oh my god it looks what is this is
coming in here yeah
what should we sit down what should we
doing a black one for the folks at home
the main thing to do is let me help with
this if you know a corner would you help
with this put it in that crotch right up
there put it in my crotch I didn't know
you were such a nature lover though that
film was I love to guess what in the
open air there tell us to tape that
that's okay I don't have to tape it
weird-looking animal huh what is it mr.
follow hair is very similar to yours
when you look at it closely here
difference is this entice this what we
should tell them what yeah it's a two
toed sloth this is a slaughter toed
sloth now look do what I'm doing entice
it like this over toward you okay but
watch out for the claws yeah was he
injured or is that it's real no sir
these are the tooth these are the
two-toed but look at this weird thing
this is characteristic of the it's it's
grabbing you at the claws well that's
scary I don't this moves so slowly can I
do it to it carefully just put it down
there why do I have to do it so clicking
first make it a little moist why do I
have to do it so carefully well because
this can bite you this can bite I don't
want to scare you or anything but put it
right up by the nose okay a little
higher Wow Oh God your whole still Oh
little bit closer very few people ever
done that successfully that's very good
with that claw is what is that were made
of it's really scary this hangs around
of course all the time this is
camouflage for living in the rainforest
in fact oh the hair you can put that in
his mouth as well okay the claw is
getting very carefully there you go the
whole thing yeah the whole thing
whatever he wants baby there you go two
claws look at those those claws are very
efficient and hey let me tell you we
should all start using this that kind of
motion let me point something out I
gotta throw a few facts out here right
why the hair seriously no one cares
about the facts
a lot of Americans love animals right
all right the hair hangs down it /
tastes like moss actually moss grows on
this animal mm-hmm it moves so slowly
and it's designed for rain of course to
be shed this is the rainforest animal
right and it just hangs all the time
right hangs around doesn't move you know
it doesn't move why is that Jim well
because if it moves a predator can see
it harpy eagles eat this so if you're
something to eat this oh yeah the big
boys
who would come near that nobody actually
these claws are extreme that'll go right
through your hand if it's aggressive
with you it was not aggressive I was a
little surprised what that'll obviously
it hasn't seen the show before yeah it's
one of the most fascinating adaptations
yeah in the wild okay
that's the sort of thing that we humans
have got to learn we're adapting also no
humans were at the top of the scale we
don't have to adapt are you oh really
yeah we're the best we can do everything
look
let's see that do that we should move on
we should get to the next animal right
this is fascinating but we got to either
more exciting things coming up
look at this Conan this is a now of
course the guy is a little weird in job
[Applause]
over here and let's donate that toward
Andy he's a real camper but not that
much why is all right there we go
now why does he have to be dressed like
a pirate what Steve's at the Sterling
Forest Renaissance Faire over tuxedo for
another couple of three weeks he's
supposed to be from the Middle Ages this
is not an eagle this is a vulture that
will take your hand off I want to tell
you that up front this is one of the
most aggressive how's your arm doing
Steve okay let me have that because this
is the fastest wouldn't mean it could
take my arm off it's just a birdie this
is the fat put this on going what I'm
gonna let you do this this is the
fastest one day
we have to make time this is the fastest
meat-eating vulture that I've ever seen
it'll do this in about five seconds do
what in five seconds leap this put it up
through his glove whoops now what with
your glove why do I have to wear this
thick protective gloves quickly up under
his glove right there
well let him hold it okay let who hold
it but Steve hold it
okay from underneath underneath alright
[Music]
[Applause]
don't do this at home but you know
Kentucky Fried Chicken that's great now
it's eating the bone now now the point
is these have to be very aggressive
around the carcass run these eat dead
animals of course very competitive he's
eating the guy now actually does she be
worried about that by the way this is
the the white back butcher from Africa
yes and you'll see 40 or 50 of these
around a carcass quite often okay just
one of those things okay all right
one more okay we have time for one more
very quickly good look out for the
closet walk home come around chair yeah
okay
should I be worried about this right
here oh yeah you seem like you're really
attentive to me we we've got new to of
Omaha insurance anyway so okay what
happens these are these just regular
they look like cats this is the real
payoff because there's so much diversity
in the natural world these are these are
two cats that very few people they've
ever seen or can identify even this is
the serval night which is a jumping cat
and I'm giving you this only because it
has an instinct to play well they
attract that don't they attack Green
electrical tape in the wild isn't that
yeah that's why you don't see much of
that electrical tape anymore look that's
right and so they show you the the two
different kinds right these are very
rare is that right if we don't watch out
there's not gonna be anything but green
electrical tape out there but we're
losing habitat very quickly we won in
the face right that's why they're going
extinct they fight amongst each other
that's I want to compare these now I
have something here I forgot that was in
my pocket but this is a this is well
protected from any of these you forgot a
giant bug on your pocket yeah this is
this is the big Miller paddock yeah I
pity your dry cleaner going through your
pocket no corner
Treach that out you can unroll it and I
don't watch out yeah there you go how
does this relate to these two that's
good now you see the point is what you
and Abby should have had in the woods
they're delicious you have to fry them a
little bit but anyway : I'm starting a
website awkward transition in TV history
that tells more about these new
adventure website WWAN dot-com exactly
we talk about all these and ranchers and
everything else terrific you know what
these animals are very cool and thank
you very much for bringing by please get
this thing out of here fast
everybody will be right back